hi and welcome to grass for data science
with network x in this tutorial i'm
going to cover how you can use
graph theory and graph algorithms to
better understand and explore
your data sets as part of
of your
data science framework
you can find
the entire slide deck and all the
jupyter notebooks that go with each
section
in the tutorial
github repository that you see on your
screen right now
i also run uh
graphs for data science self stack
that covers every
once
every couple of weeks or every month a
different application of a graph
algorithm or a
graph analysis approach to a real-world
data set they encourage you to subscribe
to see something you are interested in
my name is bruno gonzalez i'm currently
a senior data scientist working at the
intersection of data science and finance
my background is in physics and computer
science but my work
dating as far back as my phd years
always revolved around using
graph approaches or graph algorithms or
as we would call them in physics complex
networks approaches to studying real
world data sets usually from some type
of online source
things such as social media twitter
wikipedia online access logs
router traces etc
please reach out to me on social media
through email
and linkedin if you have any questions
suggestions comments and so on without
further ado let's get started
our tutorial will be divided into four
sections
each section corresponds to a different
uh real-world data set you're going to
be using a different data set and
exploring a different dataset in each of
these four sections and each section has
associated with it also
in a jupiter notebook that covers all
the material that we're we're going to
go through in the slide decks here so i
encourage you
at the end of each section to go to the
github repository and work with the
jupyter notebook so they get a better
understanding
of exactly how these approaches work and
how you can apply them to real world
data sets
we're going to start with a simple
graphs 101 type introduction for this
we're going to use the airline
transportation network which is a
well-known
network
that has
easily available
data that you can download from
the bureau of transportation statistics
website
in section two we're going to be looking
at searching and navigating on graphs
so essentially how to get directions and
for this we're going to use the
openstreetmap
dataset that we're going to query using
the
osm nx
package
section three we're gonna be focusing on
graph
connectivity how is the
graph connected
weekly connected strongly connected and
so on and for this we're going to be
using
a sample of the bitcoin transaction
network so we're going to use these
graph algorithms essentially to identify
wallets to identify sets of
bitcoin addresses that are controlled by
the same person or
or institution
and finally on in part four we're going
to have a very quick overview of some
properties of social networks and for
this we're going to use a small
twitter reply network that
we can obtain
from the
stanford network repository
so let's say sorry first question is
what exactly is a graph and why do i
sometimes say graphs and sometimes say
networks
a network
is essentially a system that's
constituted by nodes which
correspond to sub-components of our
system that are interconnected by links
and these links can correspond to any
type of connection relationship
interaction etc
in physics which is my background we
tend to use the word network
as as part of our our jargon
mathematicians for instance tend to and
computer scientists depending on the
context tend to use more the the word
graph
in practice i use them
more or less interchangeably
although depending on who you ask some
might say that there are some
technical differences with networks
being a subset of graphs
for our for our purposes you can just
think of graphs and networks as being
the same thing the two different words
to mean the same thing
mathematically a network or a graph is
simply a set of vertices so these are
our components and edges connecting
vertices the edges are just
a tuple
of two
nodes
v and v prime in our in our notation
and we can distinguish between directed
edges meaning that there is a link a
directed link an arrow pointing from
node v to node v prime or undirected
links which essentially means that you
can travel along the edge
in either direction
an easy
way of thinking about it is you have
one-way streets or two-way streets
these streets can also be wider or with
more lanes
or narrower and this would correspond
for example to the
weight of the of the edge so we can
associate a numerical value to each edge
that represents the capacity of the edge
how long the edge is or any other type
of numerical property we might be
interested in
now that we have a quick overview of the
notation and the basic concept of what a
graph of the network is
let's look at a few practical examples
one that i'm sure you're very familiar
with
it's facebook here each node is a
facebook user
the links or the edges are essentially
friendship relationships between
facebook users
as you know
if i'm your friend on facebook you're
also my friend so the links are
undirected in this case
so this is known as a social network and
in this specific example and on online
social network because the individual
nodes represent
individual people
a classical example of another of a
social real-world social network
instead of the online social network is
a zachary karate club so this is the
social network of a university karate
club in the 70s
where each node in this network
corresponds to an actual
member of that club
you see from just looking at this
picture that you have two nodes that are
highly connected that have many
uh links and these are the two main
instructors
this
network became famous because
the two instructors had the falling off
and the network essentially broke in two
so it's a classical example of how
networks break and how communities form
within networks
another good example is that of
scientific collaborations here what we
have is that each node
is a scientist
and two scientists two nodes are
connected whenever they co-author a
paper together and for this specific
data set we're actually using
the prl
so physical review letters
database of papers and who published
this one
another historical example is the
florentine weddings which essentially
describes the marriage relationship
between families in
in florence in italy and that
essentially helps us understand how the
melody became such a prominent family
in in florence's essentially controlled
the the entire city simply because they
were extremely central in this network
and they were able to create these
alliances
another one of my favorite examples is a
face-to-face contact network in a
primary school and this was
a work done
by
some researchers in france and italy
where essentially they gave little
badges to children in primary school so
from first grade to fifth grade each
grade has two classes a and b
and the little badges what they do
essentially they measure whenever two
children interact with one another face
to face so you can see here how exactly
you have a lot of information about the
structure of the social relationships
between the children you can see how
children tend to associate with other
children in their class or within
their age range more or less
you have very few connections between
for example fifth grade students and
first grade students but you have a lot
more between first and second grade
second and third and so on
i'll just summarize a graph it's simply
mathematical objects that has nodes and
edges the nodes are individual elements
the edges represent the connections
between them
the degree of the node is simply the
number of edges that are connected to
that node if the edges are directed you
can speak of in degree and out degree so
nodes going coming in and nodes going
out rather edges coming in and edges
going out
the edges can be weighted so you can
have a numerical value associated with
them and they can be directed or
undirected
typically you will find graphs and graph
data sets that come in one
of these
typical representations the most common
one perhaps
is the edge list so this is simply a
list or a
most commonly a text file
where each row corresponds to an
individual edge
and you have
in each row the two nodes that
constitute the edge and maybe some other
information about the edge itself like
the weight or some other attribute
a more mathematically convenient
uh representation is that of the
adjacency matrix and here what you have
is an
a matrix that
has n rows and n columns and here n is
simply the number of nodes
and each element on this matrix is
either zero or one
one representing that there is an edge
zero d there is no edge
uh for in the case of unweighted
networks
if
the values of the elements of the matrix
are simple are not
equal to one so they have some other
numerical value then that would
correspond to an awaited network
a third representation which is very
useful when you're thinking about how to
actually create and represent this data
structure in memory is out of the
adjacency list or a dictionary and here
all we have is a
list of all the nodes and for each node
you have a source each node is the key
and associated with that key you have
the list of all the other nodes it is
connected to along with any attributes
of those
edges
independently of what representation you
choose
if the network is undirected you can
save some memory space you can reduce
your storage requirements simply by
keeping only one edge direction so if
you have an edge between nodes a and b
you keep only a b for example and not ba
with the understanding that every time
you see a b that implies also a
connection from b to a
so let's consider a simple example we
have here the
the small graph on the right hand
side of the slide
and this is what the edge list
representation for this graph would look
like so we have
uh
in the first row a b that represents the
link the edge between nodes a and node b
then a c a e and so on
if we wanted to include weights in this
representation then each tuple so each
row of this list would have the
numerical value of the weight next to it
is the third
element of this tuple
one thing to note here is that
node f which is isolated in this graph
never appears in the edge list
no this is of course
due to the fact that f doesn't actually
have any edges associated with them
with it
and so it's excluded from the edge list
this is a way of highlighting the fact
that the edge list in particular only
includes
unless you modify it in some way only
includes the
nodes that actually
have degree
equal to one or more
the adjacency matrix then will give us
this
matrix that we have here we need to have
some way of mapping the node ids
to the
rows and columns of the matrix
in this case it's relatively simple we
just associate
a number 0 1 2 3 and so on with each
letter of the alphabet and then you can
map it directly
you will see that if the
network is
undirected this matrix will be diagonal
if you don't allow which is a very
common case
self loops so self edges
so an edge from b to b for example and
that means that the diagonal of this
matrix is always zero
finally the adjacency list or or
dictionary representation is simply a
dictionary
where you're mapping each
node to all the
other nodes it is connected to
here you can actually include
the
nodes with zero
and just simply by creating a key in the
dictionary that maps to
an empty list
or another empty dictionary
now that we have a way of representing
graphs
let's look at our first data set so here
we're going to consider the airline
transportation network we're going to
get this data from the bureau of
transportation statistics that collects
a huge
amount of information about the
transportation infrastructure of the u.s
one of the databases that's available in
this website is the t100 domestic
segment table it essentially contains
information about flights between any
two airports serviced by a us carrier so
what this means is most airports in the
world will be included
most of the flight
almost in the totality of flights within
the u.s
will also be included
and you also have some international
flights that are operated by u.s
airlines or u.s carriers
in this specific example a specific data
set each row corresponds to one edge in
this edge list type format
it actually corresponds to one
individual flight
so a flight happening at a specific date
at a specific time so if you have
multiple flights between the same pair
of airports as you usually have daily
flights and so on this will correspond
to multiple roads in this table
the airports here we're going to
consider them to be the individual nodes
the edges will be these individual
flights
the weight on our edges is simply the
number of passengers traveling
from this origin to this destination
for simplicity and to make our lives a
little bit easier we're going to
aggregate the total number of passengers
so instead of considering individual
flights we're considering individual
connections
and then and the weight of these
connections will simply be the total
number of passengers traveling
from the orange to destination in total
over the course of a year which is the
time spent covered by our data set
so essentially what we have is a
directed
weighted graph
directed because the flights started the
origin ended at the destination
waited because we have a number of
passengers traveling
the nodes in our graph are simply the
airports
for simplicity we're going to focus on
the airports and flights within the
contiguous 40 48 states
we
represent the flights as being the edges
and the weight of the edge as being the
number of passengers being the width of
the line connecting the two airports so
this is essentially what our
network
looks like so you can see that there are
immediately some patterns that appear
you have a lot of flights
going up and down
the east coast you have a large number
of flights also traveling from coast to
coast and then several other
smaller regional flights
these are the one of the main
fundamental properties of
of a network is the degree distribution
so the node has degree k
where k is the number of edges that it
connects to
if the network is directed then you can
distinguish between in degree so number
of incoming edges and now degree number
of outgoing
hedges
you can define the degree sequence so
this is simply the ordered sequence
of the degree of each of the nodes
and the degree distribution which is
simply the relative frequency of the
relative probability that if i pick a
node at random it will have degree k so
this is a
relatively simple
summary of the connectivity properties
of a network
empirical networks actually have a wide
range of degree distributions the most
common ones are poissonian gaussian
or or power law distribution
poissoning distributions tend to be
characteristic of random or geometric
processes
we're going to look at them somewhat
briefly later on and power law
distributions tend to be very common
in any type of process or any type of
network that results from
a process with some physical constraints
such as preferential attachment meaning
that the rich get richer so nodes with
higher degree
that some nodes will have extremely high
degree and other nodes will have
relatively small degrees so this is
known also as the 80 20 rule coming uh
originally defined by pareto in in
economics that says essentially 80 of
the wealth is owned by just 20 of the
population
also popularized in the early 2000s as
the long tail
idea
and to give you an idea of how
the distribution impacts the structural
network we have here a quick comparison
between two networks with two very
different degree distributions
on the left we have the interstate
network where here each node is a city
the links connecting the nodes the edges
connecting the nodes are the interstate
highway system well on the right hand
side we have a similar network where the
nodes again are cities but now
the edges connecting the cities
are
airline flights like in the online
transportation network
and you see that the structure of the
network looks very different
on one hand an inter
state
network
you have
all know most nodes with a relatively
well defined
degree so they all have roughly around
the same number of of connections
while on the
case of the online network you have this
very broad
degree distribution that essentially
correspond means that you have some hubs
some very central
airports
and a lot of peripheral airports with
very few connections
indeed when we plot
the degree distribution the in and the
outer gate distribution for the bts data
set you find
that it looks linear on a log log scale
and this is a classical signature of a
power law distribution
of course you could also perform
maximum likelihood estimation
of the exponent of this of this this
distribution to identify exactly what
the exponent is
to give you some more information about
the structure of the network for our
purposes let's just say we agree that
this is a parallel distribution at least
a very broad tail distribution where
most nodes have degree one or two and a
few nodes have several hundred
connections
now of course the way the nodes are
connected one another is also important
so this is just the id of the nearest
neighbors so the neighbors of a node are
the nodes that it's directly connected
to that sit on the opposite side of the
edges and correlations so correlations
are essentially how
likely it is that the node of degree k
will be
connected to a node of degree k prime
so you can derive this expression
relatively simple so you can get a joint
probability distribution p k k prime
which is simply the number of node
number of edges connecting nodes to
degree k and other three k prime
normalized by a constant which is simply
the average degree of the network times
the number of nodes in the network
from the simple expression you can of
course re-obtain the degree distribution
but also the conditional probability
which is the one that's most interesting
for our purposes so the probability of a
node of an edge connected to anode of
degree k prime if you know or given that
you know that on the other side of the
edge it starts at the node of degree k
this gives us a
two point
function so k and k prime
that is hard to analyze and to end to
visualize so it's
actually
commonly summarized
using the
average degree distribution of the
nearest neighbors of a node as a
function of the degree of that node so
this stick represents the k and then of
k
average
and this
simple
expression is actually enough to give us
a lot of information about the structure
of the network
you typically find
that this function follows one of three
behaviors it can have an
upward trend so that
nodes of degree k tend to have
neighbors also of high degree k
you can have a downward trend
where
nodes of small degree
k
are
typically connected to nodes of high
degree k and vice versa
or it can be uncorrelated where you have
no
relationship so that
the function is actually flat
uh on the in the first case where you
have an upward slope we call the network
assortative
and this is typical of social networks
so famous people interact with other
famous people
uh unknown people interacted unknown
people well on the other hand
technological networks like the online
network tend to be disassortative
meaning that
you have hubs and you have
smaller airports or smaller nodes
connected to these hubs so that act as
more efficient ways of distributing
or transporting some
good let's say
when we plot the degree distribution the
degree correlation so the average degree
of the nearest neighbor as a function of
the degree
for uh the bts inflation network you
find
a clear deductive trend so the
the value starts going down and then you
have also
this kind of hump around
k equals 100 that essentially
corresponds to finite size effects which
means this is due to the fact that the
network is not infinite and that
essentially only sampling
a small fraction of the total
possible
connections of this network
you can also summarize the
average degree of various neighbors the
functions agree using the
assortativity coefficient so this is
just the pearson correlation coefficient
of the degrees of a node at each side of
the edge
of a positive value of r means that
nodes of high degree tend to connect
preferentially to nodes of low degree
or rather to nodes of high degree and
vice versa known as the rich club effect
or preferential attachment
a negative
value of the solidity coefficient means
that nodes of high degree tend to
connect to nodes of low degree so you
have a hierarchical or a hub and spoke
tree-like structure
this slide we have a quick summary of
several
empirical empirical networks along with
some other properties but in particular
we have on the second to last
column we have the value of the
assortativity coefficient and you can
see that social networks tend to have
with small exceptions
uh
a positive a valuable subjectivity
technological networks and biological
networks and
contrary tend to have a negative value
of the assorted
sensitivity
we can also look at
the
function of k in so the
number
of
edges arriving at the node versus k out
the number of edges pointing out from
the node and these of course would tend
to be
highly colorated or strongly correlated
this means in particular
one direct concept of this is that you
tend to have no dead end airport so you
typically don't have
airports that
receive a lot of flights but don't have
a lot of outgoing flights so where
people
mostly just arrive and never leave or
vice versa
as we mentioned edge weights can
represent connection strength
so how many passengers how many cars
how strong the connection is connection
frequency so how often do we travel
between these two cities how
often do we call one another and so on
also physical distance so could be
flight time could be distance in miles
and so on
the node strength is essentially the
weighted
version of
the degree simply the sum of all the
weights of all the edges that are
incoming or not going from the net from
that specific node
and of course weights tend to be
strongly related with network topology
so when we plot the distribution of
weights
for our
airline transportation network you see
again that you have a broad tail
distribution with some
nodes having a weight of a thousand or
less so in the course of a year only a
thousand people traveled along that edge
and a few
edges that have
weights of several million passengers
means that you had several million
people traveling along that edge
a similar pattern is observed also for
the strength and here we consider the in
strength and the out strength
and you
and here you see that you have
four major hubs
so
large airports like for instance atlanta
o'hare uh
atlanta o'hare in chicago jfk new york
and so on you have
these large airports that handle several
tens of millions of passengers per year
not surprisingly the in strength and the
out strength are also strongly
correlated which essentially means that
most flights are also returned flights
so you have a flight going from a to b
you typically also have
a flight from b to a
and in general of course there are
exceptions when you're moving or so on
if you're if one person is flying from a
to b
a few days later or a few weeks later he
or she will also fly back from b to a
as one might expect there's also a
strong
relationship between the degree and the
strength nodes in this case airports
with higher in or out degree will tend
to have correspondingly higher
in or out strength but of course the
relationship is not trivial and this
essentially points
us to
the relative importance
or the relative
uh structural location of each specific
airport so you can have
airports with
relatively small number of flights that
have a lot of traffic
while most airports tend to have
relatively small number of flights and
also relatively small number of
passengers traveling
so this brings us to the end of the
first
section so here i would
recommend that you
stop playing the video and jump over to
the github repository and explore
the first notebook
the names of the notebooks match the
names of the sections and they're also
numbers from one to four
and they cover every single
topic that we go through in the slide so
you can look at the code and understand
better what it's doing in fact every
single in
empirical
figure that you saw like the degree
distribution
weight distributions and so on is
generated from these notebooks so you
can
observe exactly how you go from the raw
data set
to the final product to the final figure
so you have the entire pipeline the
entire
sequence of
analysis that you have to perform which
i believe will give you
a
leg up when it comes to
applying the
these approaches and these analysis in
your own
practical applications
now let's start with
section two searching in graphs so here
what we're trying to understand now is
now that we have a better
understanding of the structure and the
topology of the graph and how nodes are
related to another how weights
impact the
the structure of the network how weights
are related to degrees and so on
we can start thinking about dynamical
processes happening on top of this in
particular we can start thinking about
how
we can
think about walking or traveling
on top of this graph
so each edge of course represents a path
connecting nodes i to j in the case of
the airline connection network that's
obvious you have an actual flight
in the case of a road network for as
we'll see here
that also corresponds with actual road
but in other applications in other type
of
networks this connection is not as clear
for example in the case of facebook you
can think of paths on this graph as
being
for instance the way that specific memes
or specific peeps pieces of information
travel along the graph so i can post
something on my wall if you're my friend
you can see it and share it with your
friends then another one of your friends
can see it and share it as well and you
can see how
this specific post or this specific meme
traveled through the network
let's start by considering just for
conceptual clarity
an adjacency matrix representation of
the network so here we have a matrix a
the typical name
and if each
edge on this
network so if each
element of this matrix corresponds to a
path connecting
nodes i and nodes j you can see that by
taking products or powers of this
adjacency matrix
you can essentially count
how many
ways that are to go from one node to
another node so there is no adjacency
matrix a
the
number of paths between nodes i and j if
they are connected is one in the case of
a direct of unweighted networks or some
other value in the case of
weighted networks
if you take the square
of the matrix then you
you're counting the number of paths
between nodes i
and j
in two steps so yeah so you go from i to
k from k to j and you're summing overall
values of k
if you take the third power then you
have the number of paths of three steps
and so on
uh one interesting property of the
square of the adjacency matrix is that
in the diagonal elements essentially
what you have is the
degree of the nodes because the only way
for you to go from node i back to node i
into steps is to visit every single one
of its neighbors
a path is any sequence of nodes where we
traverse each edge at most one
at most once
and the sequence of nodes that we see
essentially corresponds to the end
result of each step that we take while a
walk
is similar to a path but has no
limitation on a number of times so it's
just any sequence of nodes that you're
visiting by traveling along the edges
you can also define the diameter of a
graph as being the average shortest path
between all
all pairs of nodes so if you measure the
the
the
minimum distance between every node i
and every node j you take the average
and you get the diameter of the network
to clarify a bit what i mean by all this
let's consider the zachary karate club i
already mentioned this essentially
corresponds to
the friendship network of two
instructors
in the character club of at the
university in the 70s
it's a relatively small network it's
easy to visualize so it makes a good
case study for us to understand a little
bit better what we are we are talking
about here
in particular one of the things we are
interested in understanding better
is how can we identify
the shortest path or the shortest
distance between pairs of nodes
in the network
there's three typical algorithms that
we're going to cover that are very
common the depth for search breadth
first search
and diker's algorithm
each of these algorithms has their pros
and cons of course the depth first
search you will essentially keep going
far away from the origin
until you reach it at the end and then
you backtrack and then you try moving
forward again and so on so eventually
you will
visit every node so you you will find a
path between the origin and any
destination that you want as long as the
graph is connected as long as there is a
path
but this is not guaranteed to be the
shortest path
on the other hand the breadth first
search
tends to explore the network in
concentric shells
so from one node you visit all of its
neighbors then all the neighbors of the
neighbors all the neighbors of the
neighborhoods of neighbors and so on
and
depth research and breadth first search
are
typically used in unweighted networks or
at least in networks for which we are
not particularly interested in
using the weights of the edges as a
metric
so we're only interested in the number
of hubs
uh dijkstra's algorithm on the other
hand
follows a somewhat similar approach to
breadth research but instead of going by
concentric shells by number of hops it
actually looks always at the shortest
path because it always takes into
account
the weight of the edge
and essentially from one step to the
next you'll keep extending
the
the shortest path that it found so far
until it reaches assassination until it
calculates and finds
the path to every node in the graph
so let's see what these look like in our
little toy network
so for depth search
in this in the examples i'm going to
consider we're going to
start always at node 0. of course in
your specific case you can start at any
node that you want and you're going to
compute the distance between node 0
and every other node in this graph
we chose node 0 because it it's
central to one part of the network and
relatively far away from the other part
so it gives us a nice
example of how far off we can stretch
out in the network
until we find the correct paths do we
find the correct way of reaching every
node
and in this visualization
you will notice that i'm displaying the
network just as i had before but now i'm
keeping
all the edges to be very thin except the
ones that i find
the ones that i try that i traverse
using
the depth research algorithm
i'm switching
node colors every time
i
i take another hop so you can see
essentially the nodes that have the same
color tend to be connected to the same
parent
and you can see how the colors seem to
be essentially randomly almost randomly
assigned throughout the network so there
are no obvious patterns
in in this this reversal because as i
said we keep
with depth first search you keep
following
edges until you reach
at that end and then you backtrack and
then you keep moving forward and so on
until eventually you will
visit every node just not
in the
most efficient way possible
by contrast we have breadth first search
as before we're starting our search from
non-zero and trying to reach every other
node
here you you can see the
concentric shell structure of of the
search by looking at the way
the colors are distributed so you can
actually see the concentric shells
represented by the callers
so this gives us a systematic
exploration of the network in these
concentric shells which means that in
the case of an undirected network it's
guaranteed to find the shortest path
because you you're only taking a new
step if you haven't found
what you're looking for yet
so it gives you a more structured view
of the network
depending on your specific application
breadth first search or depth-first
search might be more useful or might be
more easily implemented in your specific
data set
dijkstra's algorithm
by contrast were now written created by
exec
dijkstra
in the mid 50s
that this
explicitly takes into account the weight
of the edges so here essentially
but
you're following a similar idea to the
breadth first search but in brexit
search essentially you had a concentric
shell
of nodes
and you wouldn't move to the on to the
next shell
until essentially you've explored this
entire shell
dexter essentially does the same thing
but in in a weighted fashion so you
don't create you don't move on to the
next step
unless of
course you already found your
destination node
and you only move on by extending the
shortest path so at each step you start
you're looking for what is the
node that has the shortest distance so
far and then you're trying to extend the
that specific path so it
because at each step you're only looking
for the smallest the shortest path
you will eventually grow
to encompass the entire network
but always with the shortest path so
mathematically you're essentially only
updating the distance to the near
to each of the neighbors by
adding that extra weight if that weight
makes the distance smaller
that
if the weight between edges i and j
makes a difference the distance from the
origin to node j smaller than it was
before
you can relatively easily modify this
algorithm to keep track not just of the
distances between the nodes between the
origin and every other node but also the
paths that it takes
to be to reach every other node so you
can extract both
the distances and also the path the
routing
instructions and how to reach that
there are a few constraints to type this
algorithm it's of course assuming that
the graph is weighted that each edge has
a has a weight
again of course you can apply it to one
weighted graph by just saying that each
edges has a weight of one
the weights have to be positive because
it's adding up the weights and checking
if the distance
becomes smaller so if there was a
negative weight
you could keep adding the same edge over
and over again and you keep reducing the
distance which of course is nonsensical
for this specific use case
and if you have unweighted graphs
eventually what you will find
is the same thing you would find with a
breath first search you're just doing it
in a more
inefficient way
so here you find again that you have
these
relatively structured exploration of the
network but you're always finding the
shortest way to reach any other node
from the origin
now that we have an understanding of how
these algorithms work and what are their
pros and cons let's look at our
data set for the section and for this
we're going to use the openstreetmap
data set you can think of openstreetmap
essentially being an open source version
of google maps or apple maps
another way of
defining it is simply is the wikipedia
of maps right you can anyone can go and
edit it so you can add information to a
specific street or a specific
intersection specific point of interest
and so on
this map is an extremely large
xml database that represents all the
nodes and not the edges nodes typically
correspond to
intersections or points of interest
edges essentially correspond to roads
connecting
nodes
it's fairly hard or at least a little
bit
complex and computational intensive
to actually extract and analyze this
a graph from this xml representation
fortunately there is the osm nx
python package that essentially allows
you to query the
the database online and extracting just
the part of the network that you
that you are interested in
openstreetmap also includes different
types of edges so you have edges that
are for driving edges that are for
walking and so on
just for biking et cetera and
essentially you can query
open the openstreetmap servers and say
give me the network for this specific
location
for and this type of edges only
so in this exam this small code snippet
here
we're essentially requesting the
road network for manhattan
that includes roads where you can drive
on
so this will return a network x object
though essentially gives us a simple way
of interacting with this graph and
applying algorithms in this graph
and essentially what we're trying to do
with this graph which is a nice
representation of the element happen
that you have here on the right hand
side of the slide
is to automatically identify what is the
best way from going
from a starting point to a final
destination
here of course because we have
weighted edges the weight in each edge
is simply the distance
the length of that piece of road
we will use
dijkstra's algorithm to essentially find
what is the shortest path connecting any
two nodes in this specific example
we're connecting
the world trade center in southern
manhattan with columbia university in
uptown manhattan
another interesting feature of
openstreetmap
networks is that each edge includes not
only the distance
the distance that it corresponds to but
also the bearing and the bearing is
essentially the angle
from two north that that
road is traveling down and this gives us
a simple way of essentially
summarizing
the results of our dijkstra algorithm
the basic and the results of century b
start at node
i
travel 10 meters to node j then 100
meters to node k and so on
and actually summarize that in a way
that's meaningful to us and it actually
can actually be useful so here i'm
giving another
short snippet of code that essentially
what it's doing is that that each
time it reaches a new node it checks
the bearings of the edge
of the incoming edge and the outgoing
edge
and if the
different in angles is
socially large it will
tell you to turn right or turn left or
turn back depending on which way the
angle is gone
on the other hand if the angles are
relatively close to one another
it
will just keep saying keep going or
continue on to this other street
the edges also have associated with them
street names so you can also check if
the street changes names
or if it remains the same street name
even though you're turning around
so this brings us to the end of part two
as i mentioned at the end of part one
there is a github
in the github repository egyptian
notebook called searching and graphs
that essentially goes through this
entire process
of exploring the zachary character club
network and then also downloading the
manhattan
open street map network and running
dexter's algorithm on on it extracting
the path on this weighted graph and then
using that path
to
extract essentially turn-by-turn
directions
and
the if you were driving from in this
specific example
from the road trade center to columbia
university will tell you exactly how to
get there
so this is a simple example of how
you using graph algorithms in your own
daily life so every time you use google
maps or apple maps for driving
directions
somewhere in the cloud google or apple
are essentially running one of these
simple routing algorithms
to help you navigate the
the city
or the country
and again i would encourage you to
explore in detail digital notebook that
reproduces this entire analysis from
scratch
let's now move on to
graph connectivity so far we mentioned
at the beginning that you can have
graphs that are not entirely connected
so we had
in our little toy example
we had node f
that didn't have any incoming edges
in practice you can actually have a
graph that's
composed of different subgraphs that
have no edges in between them so this
so you'd say that
the graph is disconnected
and as our example of
data set that we're going to use to
explore graph connectivity we're going
to be talking about the bitcoin
transaction net so you might have heard
the bitcoin bitcoin was the first
popular cryptocurrency it was introduced
by satoshi nakamoto in 2009 and it
provided essentially the first anonymous
peer-to-peer blockchain
based cryptocurrency
in
the last 12 years or so
literally thousands of other
cryptocurrencies have been launched
some using the same ideas of the same
framework as bitcoin others taking
completely different approaches
uh for a particular example we're gonna
use the kaggle bitcoin transaction data
set that allows you to download a set of
1.5 million transaction records
but before we can actually use this data
set and able to extract a graph from it
we actually have to understand it a
little bit better of how
bitcoin is organized and how it's
structured
bitcoin as i mentioned is called a
blockchain based cryptocurrency and it's
called
it's known as a blockchain because you
have blocks of transactions
and each block refers to the
immediately previous block
in the long continuous chain
this is done in in a fancy way using
essentially cryptographic
techniques
that mean that if you try to modify any
of the blocks
you have to modify every other
consecutive block because otherwise the
you're essentially breaking the links if
you try to make any changes
and this
results in this secure
unmodifiable data structure because it's
extremely computationally intensive and
it's very computationally costly to
actually modify and to recompute the
entire blockchain from scratch
simply because you made this a change
each of these blocks
in addition to some header information
all contains a set of transactions
transactions you can think of them as
being nodes
and they're defined the fundamental
concept
of the bitcoin blockchain a transaction
essentially has
set one or more inputs
and produces one or more output
the inputs are essentially amounts of
bitcoin that are coming in to this
transaction while the outputs are
amounts of bitcoin that are going out of
this transaction
so you can think of the node
as as being an encapsulation of
the
flows of money or floats of bitcoin
coming in being distributed to
other accounts so you can
the inputs from one transaction
are simply the outputs of previous
transactions so you can build a chain of
or a graph rather directed a cyclical
graph
directed because
you can the outputs of one transaction
can only go towards inputs of a future
transaction so you have a
temporal ordering of the transactions
and it's a cyclical of course because
you do have this temporal ordering you
can't use as the input for a pass
transaction and output of a future
transaction
the total sum of inputs to the sum of
the amount of the inputs has to equal
the total sum
of the amounts of the output
any difference between the total inputs
and the total outputs is considered to
be a fee that you're paying
to
the
bitcoin miners so that they will process
the
your transaction
you don't have to actually pay any fee
unless you want to but
miners can choose which transactions
they process
so transactions that have larger fees
will be processed
faster than transactions with
smaller fees
now it's easy to see that you do have
this directly cyclical graph this graph
will not necessarily be
connected right you can have
different addresses different
transactions different inputs
that never interact so that one part of
the network never actually touches the
other part of the network so this brings
us to the idea of components and here
we're kind of
zooming out a little bit and moving back
towards
a more general graph theory approach or
graph theory concepts so going back to
our simple
toy and network
and here we
remove the few edges so that we have
three different components
so we have disconnected nodes which can
be their own individual components like
in this case node f
and then you have two other components
in this case a b and c and
for one and e and d for the other one
each of these components
is connected by definition like
all the nodes are connected to
each other
an intuitive way of thinking about it is
if i were to pick up if this was a
physical graph and now to pick up
node b
nodes a and c would come
will come along
while nodes e d and f would remain on
the on the table
the largest component of a graph is
often called the giant connected
component or the largest connected
component
graphs that have a single component
are called connected
in the case of directed graphs you have
to distinguish between essentially two
different cases
you can have a strongly connected graph
and what this means is that each node is
accessible from every other node
while following only the direction of
the edges
or you can have a weakly connected
component where you can go from each
node to
every other node
if you ignore the edge directions
so let's consider a simple a simple
example so here we have a network that
obviously has two
uh large sub networks two large
components
and these are weakly connected
components so each edge here
is added by a little arrow the
correspond that shows you the direction
that you're traveling and along this
edge
and you can see that if you start
on a node on the component on the left
there is no way to reach another
component on the right
and if you simply ignore the direction
of the edges then you can go from
any node to any other node within a
given component
so the weakly connected components in
the case of directed
networks is similar to the
intuition i gave you of picking up the
graph
picking up a node and checking which
other nodes come attached to it
in the case in this
mental image
the direction of the arrows is not
meaningful just do you have a connection
or don't you have a connection so this
is the simplest
version and the more in some cases the
most intuitive version of the
way of determining components in the
graph on the other hand
for strongly connected components you're
imposing the constraint the other
constraint that you're
only allowed to travel along the
direction of the edges
and essentially what this would do is it
would
break down
the weekly connected components into
small sub components
so here we have in the
instead of having the two we click on
components as before we have several
other components where each of the
previous
components actually broken down into
smaller
pieces
and here i'm representing each of the
components by a different color and you
can see that we have essentially one two
three four five six seven eight nine
different components even though we have
still just the same
set of 16 edges
or the 16 nodes that we had before
when we apply
the
weekly connected component to the
bitcoin transaction network what we find
is a very large
distribution of component sizes and here
essentially each weekly connected
component
corresponds to an individual wallet and
wallets are defined essentially as being
addresses controlled by the same
individual the same institution
now
this becomes apparent just becomes
obvious when you consider that for you
to spend
uh
the output of a transaction for it to be
able to spend your your bitcoin you have
to control the address that contains
that bitcoin so you have to control
essentially the output of a transaction
so
any
addresses that are used as inputs for a
single transaction have to be controlled
by the same person
and that's why when you use the client
components they identify the component
directly connected
component algorithm to identify the
really connected components here such
identifying these wallets these clusters
of accounts
that are controlled by the same
individual the same institution
and even in this small sample of just
1.5 million transactions
you immediately see that
most individuals can have only one or
two addresses
while a few individuals control tens of
thousands of addresses
uh these are non-health whales
and a simple example of these would be
also
online exchanges
that essentially handle
the wallets for me
for millions of individual users
so you can see
in this plot we're plotting the fraction
of the cumulative fraction of addresses
as a function of the component size
that essentially half of the total
addresses
belong to components of cells less than
10. so they're in small wallets
where
while a few
addresses belong to these very large
wallets of 100 000
addresses or more
this is the end of part three i'll
remind you that there is in the github
repository the
corresponding github the corresponding
jupyter notebook
implementing the
weekly connected component to strongly
connected component algorithms
and also processing
the bitcoin transaction network that we
obtained from from kaggle that is the
necessary data files are actually
included inside the data
directory
of the
of the github repository so
the whole
notebook is self-contained and
reproduces the entire analysis
essentially regenerates all the figures
that were used in this specific part
of our
tutorial
now let's move on to
the fourth and final part
of our tutorial we're going to look at
social networks in particular using the
twitter
a sample of a twitter reply network
before we do that already we have to
introduce some new concepts
and one of the consoles we have to
introduce is that of a random graph so i
mentioned briefly in the beginning that
some graphs are random and these tend to
have
poissonian or gaussian degree
distributions the most common
model the most
famous model for
a random graph is that known as the
erdos rainy graph
which is created in 1959 by two
hungarian mathematicians paulus
erdog and alfred reni
and the idea behind this model is very
simple you use so this was actually
generate a synthetic network a model
network
uh
you can start with n disconnected nodes
and then you check each pair of nodes so
all the possible pairs
and
for each possible pair you flip a coin
and if the coin comes out heads you
connect you create an edge between these
two
nodes if it comes out tail you don't
of course this will not be a fair coin
this will be a coin the only comes up
heads with probability p
in general the value of p will be much
smaller than one
so be a very unfair coin
if you do this process
you will end up with p over 2 times n n
minus 1 edges so this essentially
the p fraction of all pairs between n
nodes
the average degree of course would just
be p n minus one this is often
summarized as simply a p n
if n is is much larger than one
so if you want to obtain a network of a
specific
average degree then you simply
have to choose p to be the average
degree divided by n
you can perform some relatively simple
algebra and find the degree the this
degree distribution
will follow this passionian
behavior and one interesting part uh
point of distribution is that there are
no hubs so all the nodes have
a number of
edges have a degree that is relatively
similar to another relatively close to
the average right you never have any
large deviations from this
in the jupiter notebook we actually
generate a network following this
algorithm and here we're showing you the
comparison between
the
the simulated network our model network
in blue and the theoretical degree
distribution in purple and you can see
it's
actually a very good agreement so that
our
algebra and our
coding skills haven't failed us yet
and now that we have this simple
example network we can introduce another
concept and this concept is that of the
clustering coefficient
crossing coefficient essentially is
telling you
how many of your friends know each other
you can think of this and you can
measure this by looking at the num
possible number of pairwise combinations
of
uh nodes of degree k
or rather of ki nodes so how many pairs
of how many friendships can you create
among your k
neighbors
this of course is just k k minus one
over two so the the classic coefficient
is the number of triangles so the number
of your friends that know each other
divided by the total number of possible
friendships by the total number of
possible edges between your friends
so to illustrate this point let's look
at a simple
example of four nodes so here we're
measuring the clustering coefficient of
node zero
in these four different scenarios
node zero
in all four cases has degree three
but in the first case and the top left
hand corner
uh it none of its neighbors know each
other so the degree is zero
and the top
right hand corner is that we added a new
edge so it created the friendship
between nodes one and those two
so now
the closing coefficient is one third so
you only have one
possible edge one edge out of the three
possible ones
the bottom left-hand corner we add the
second edge this time connecting nodes
two to nodes three so now the clustering
coefficient is two-thirds
because we have two of the possible
edges connecting
our friends and finally in the bottom
right hand corner we have class in
degree of one because all of my three
friends know each other they're all
friends with one another
so you can see how this simple value is
giving me a lot of information about the
neighborhood of a node and how well
connected
its neighbors are
in practice what we typically do is you
take the you compute the classroom
coefficient for each node so in this
case it's just for node zero and then
you take the average across all nodes
and when you look uh take the average
across all nodes
you you'll find that social networks
tend to have relatively high
clustering
values
while other networks technological
networks biological et cetera will have
practically zero clustering networks in
the case of the dr dos training graph
that we introduced
before
the only way for two of my friends to be
connected
is for the edge between them to be
to come up heads when i flip my coin the
probability for that is p so the
clustering coefficient will be p
so it's uh
so we are showing that this simple
algebraic model produces a classic
coefficient that's very small because
it's not
considering any correlations between the
way the nodes are connected
another concept we have to introduce is
that of the network diameter so we kind
of briefly mentioned this as being the
average distance shortest distance
between
between nodes and the concept was
originally introduced by
stanley milgram in the late 70s
where he was trying to answer this
question of how many friendship steps
separate on average any two people in
the u.s
and
he measured this by
essentially running
an experiment where he asked
participants in kansas and nebraska
to send a letter to a specific stock
broker in boston
the trick of course was that they
couldn't just mail the letter directly
to
the stock broker they had to give it in
hand to someone that they knew
well
that they think might be closer might
know that or at least be more likely to
to know the stock broker
he did this for several
um
hundred
letters several hundred participants
only a quarter of the letters actually
reached their destination of course many
narrators got lost somewhere along the
way
and at the end when you look at the
statistics of all the letters that
arrived in the end there were only 44
letters that arrived
you you find that
on average it took six steps to reach
the
the broker so this became known in
popular cultures the six degrees of
separation the idea being
being that any two people
in the u.s or even in the world are
separated by at most on average
six
steps
this also resulted
it with the
advent of
large online their insights in the earl
in the late 90s and early 2000s
with the six degrees of kevin bacon so
this uses the imdb the internet movie
database
database to connect actors to
kevin bacon so it became a game
of trying to find
a path connecting any actor to kevin
bacon the reason kevin bacon was
was chosen specifically is because he's
an actor that worked on many different
movies of different genres with many
different actors so it's a very central
uh actor is an actor with a very large
degree
so here showing you an example of how to
connect angelina jolie to
kevin bacon
saying angelina jolie was in the good
shepherd 2006
with robert de niro which was in
sleepers in 1996 with kevin bacon
and here you'll note that this path
actually covers nodes of two different
types you have actors and you have
movies so this is known as a bipartite
graph so this is a graph where you have
nodes of two different kinds
and you only allow edges from nodes of
one kind to nodes of the other kind and
never within its own
more recently around 2012 facebook
decided to perform a similar experiment
to what stanley milgram did essentially
measured the average shortest path
between all of its
users
and they found that
the average distance
between all pairs of users in facebook
it's only four steps so
it seems to indicate that between the
50s
and between 1956 when milgram randy's
experiment in 2012 when facebook did
that the world became smaller that
facebook somehow brought us together
now that we have the concepts of
clustering the concepts of shortest path
or diameter we can introduce the watch
straw guts model so it's strongest model
it's again like the elder shiny model uh
simple theoretical model to generate
artificial networks
that have specific properties it was
introduced in 1998 by duncan watts
and stephen strogat
that essentially tries to go beyond the
arduous training type graph
to add this extra component of height
clustering
which is something you see in real world
networks like social networks but it's
impossible to reproduce with their dos
or any
type models
and also the relatively shortest
diameter of the graft it's also typical
of social networks
uh the way the water gas models work is
essentially you start with a random
rather with a regular graph with a
regular circle or ring of nodes each
node is connected to k over two
neighbors to the left and camera two
neighbors to the right
and then with probability p you rewire
each of these edges at random
so as you increase the probability p
you're moving closer and closer to the
erdos rainy
limit
if p is zero you remain a perfectly
regular graph but for intermediate
uh values of p something interesting
happens
what you end up with this is a graph
that still has a large clustering
coefficient just like the ring network
does because you're connected to all
your neighbors
to all your k neighbors and they're also
very highly connected among themselves
but by
rewiring some of the edges they're
actually able to create shortcuts in the
structure of the graph
and essentially reduce the diameter of
the graph
so
when you do when you scan several values
of p this is the behavior
you observe so here i'm plotting
the blue stars
the clustering coefficient but the
purple
circles
correspond to the diameter of the
network and you can see as we increase
the value of p
the clustering coefficient remains
relatively high and then it starts
decreasing
while the diameter of the net
decreases very quickly after that so for
intermediate values that i'm
highlighting here
in light orange you can have both a high
clustering
and a low diameter which is much closer
to the real world networks
this was a good step forward
in understanding the structure of
real-world data sets real-world networks
in practice for most of the networks
that you're interested in like the
airport transportation network we saw in
the beginning you have to use more
sophisticated models like preferential
attachment type models
that
also have these properties but
are able to produce broad-tailed
distributions
for our purposes the introducing these
two models is enough just to explain
what
we are we are trying to do for this
section as i mentioned the dataset we're
going to be using is a
small sample of the twitter network you
might be familiar from uh
with twitter which is an online social
network the edges are directed i can
follow you and you may or may not follow
me so they are just pointing one
direction
and you can have different kinds of
edges so the typical edges you find are
the follower network so i follow you or
you follow me
on top of that you can also have
interaction networks so you can have
mentions when i tag you in a tweet or i
reply to one of your tweets
or i can retweet something you posted or
you can read it somewhere i posted so
that creates these three
layers on the graph of course the nodes
in each of the layer are the same
they're just
the individual users but the different
edges correspond to
different ways of interacting different
social
structures
in particular we're going to use the
higgs discussion network so this is a
small sample of twitter
users discussing the announcement of the
higgs boson in 2012 a couple of years
later this would be the
nobel prize in physics and let's say in
2014
if i remember correctly maybe 2013.
so it was a big event because people
have been speculating particular higgs
has been speculating about this boson
that is able to create mass essentially
is responsible for
particles in the universe having mass
having weight
i've been speculating about it since the
60s so finding it experimentally was a
big uh it was a big deal
so this was
officially announced on july 4 2012.
the data set you can download from the
stanford network analysis process
project and it contains
38 000 nodes and about 32 000 edges
the strongest connected component is
only 322
nodes while the weekly connected
component is over 12 000 nodes
and
the snap projects of the stanford
network analysis project actually
includes the the reply network the
following network and the retweet
network we're going to look just at the
reply network
as you might expect discussion networks
tend to be
uh typically disconnected so i can reply
to you you reply to me but you don't
interact with anybody else
so this results in a very large number
of components so here we're plotting the
the number of nodes for each of the 30
000 or so components we have in our
network and also the distribution of
component sizes so we see that most
components have only one or two
nodes
while the largest component has several
hundred nodes
this is what the largest component
looks like
so this are the 322 nodes that are part
of the
largest strongly connected component
here we're representing also the arrows
connecting in the edges to represent the
way
these uh replies
worked so you can see that the structure
of the network
the size of the node corresponds to the
degree so you can see that larger nodes
are
more well connected than smaller nodes
and once you measured the clustering
coefficient and the diameter of the
network you'll find that it has
relatively well-behaved values
regressing coefficient and
and the diameters we'd expect
you can find the
final notebook for this tutorial
in the github repository as before it
includes all the analysis for the other
drain network the western network and
even the higgs
reply network
so
this is all that i have to present to
you today i truly hope you enjoyed this
tutorial i will again
recommend you sign up for the grass
forsythe sub stack
on online so you'll get more content
from me directly
feel free to reach out to me on social
media on the website through email even
on linkedin
with any questions or comments
that you might have thank you so much it
was a pleasure